now I'd like to introduce you to today's
presenters Professor Bob Sutton in
hayagreeva rel and John Willie John
Willie is a partner at Greylock as well
as on the board of directors of Cru
Sigma angel technologies caffeine Code
for America and more John is also the
former CEO of Mozilla and a Stanford
University alum he's also a co-teacher
in the Graduate School of Business
people operations course with huggy Rao
also we have Bob Sutton who is a
professor of management science and
engineering in the Stanford School of
Engineering and a professor and
professor huggy Rao is professor of
organizational behavior at the Stanford
Graduate School of Business
together they have her in a book titled
scaling up excellence hosted a podcast
titled friction on organization of
culture and our academic directors of
our online professional education
program
Stanford innovation and entrepreneurship
certificate now that we've welcome Tim I
will turn it over to them great thank
you so very much in that it's a do you
like to be here this morning with John
in the one hand and Bob on the other in
our plan is to actually have a
conversation and maybe take questions in
the last 10 minutes or so is that right
in that wonderful so let's actually
bring in John right away why the word
people operations might not HR why not
personnel yes you know I'm not sure who
coined the term I think my guess is that
is what they call it at Google Pharisees
lastly Berkeley joining people office at
Google call it this I think it was
intentional to reframe it to everybody
who worked there and I think the HR you
know Human Resources human capital all
the things that would call these things
for four years and they have a they have
a bit of a fixed fixed sensibility I
think or people ops is a sense that
people operations you're trying to make
a make a system that runs over time and
I think that something that has feedback
loops and changes in the laws over time
that's my sense of why of why that terms
of allthe I've always liked it because
it's more active active than an asset so
when you were actually looking at
startups
what do you particularly pay attention
to when you think of people operate
yeah I think we talked about that you
talk about this a lot on our class the
business school it really depends on the
stage of companies so a lot of times
people come to us in the business school
and you talk about hiring they say and
they think of hiring as well I get my
resumes from my HR department and I get
the best resumes I like and I go talk to
this particular salon and from what we
found for startups for even for bigger
companies like Mozilla when we were
there that's the best candidates don't
just go in the front Thor it's an act
it's again like the word people out to
stuff it's an active-active orientation
which is recruiting it's like how do you
even get people to know about the
company how to get people to care how do
you get people to come and it's a
two-way conversation rather than sitting
back evaluating so III have a question
related to that is it your experience
it's better to hire people who have
worked together before and to have them
recruit one another rather than just
aggregating the basket but to actually
bring people have some experience
together yes I think this is a tricky
and long depression I think that it sort
of if you play it out it's like a few
hire people do you know you'll tend to
be very much yeah good look like you got
the same background as you that kind of
stuff and it's an old African proverb
like if you want to go gonna go fast go
alone it can go far go together and I
think of that is like does it start to
scale up I think when you when you're
starting you have to have some shared
background because it's just the demands
are too high huh you've got three or
four or ten people all trying to do
things and if you don't have shared
background there's no then you have to
figure everything out from first
principles so you know I think it helps
to have people who have worked together
who know each other I think in the limit
though you get a big company then you
want to be diverse because I think worse
will give you more robust ideas more
strength and so the questions like so I
think we know that when you start going
to be a little homogeneous now there's
no finish or you finish just and you'll
be a little diverse those questions
heavy time so that's it is we know
including from you know our colleague
Kathy eisenhardt there's evidence that
shows when people have haven't worked
together before that their startups are
more likely to be successful and since
we're sitting on the Stanford campus
right now you Litton packard are the
famous examples they did classes
together and they figured out they could
work together and hence what was a once
great technology company was formed by
them but the diversity things
interesting so there's an argument then
you should have diverse friends early
and you've got both for life yeah the
question it's more about diversity of
it's about the burst pathways of thought
and so I think you really want so I
think the question is more like if you
start with the core whose work together
I think it's much more like this exceed
you can look at almost any startup it
starts with a core of people who know
each other righty-o
cuz that said like sure they'll also
trust mmm it's very hard to trust people
who don't come from some shared about
him but the question is like within 10 -
first 10 people the first 20 people the
first 50 people how do you become how do
you build more and more new diversity
you know there's a lot of companies that
will start and you know unfortunate will
be the first five people will be men
right and then they'll hire their
friends or generally the next 15 people
um and then I connect say you know you
got the 20% company it's all dudes it's
like how do you hire the first female
into that group like good luck into
there are other companies like you know
Bret Taylor oh I'm here famously started
equipped and they they recruited for
diversity from nearly at the beginning
and as a result they had something like
40% women on the engineering team when
they were getting to scale up put it up
off by Salesforce so I think it's tricky
I think but I think if you I think you'd
have to be a little homage just when you
start you have to be honest so for our
readers we I just want to draw your
attention to that wheel on the slide
there that wheel actually represents a
framework that John and I along with Sue
J Jasper we use it in the course on
people operations start up to scale up
it's actually built around an acronym
called father John accuses me of liking
acronyms and I plead guilty to the
charge so the acronym farther stand the
F stands for finding people they as for
aligning them the r is for real-time
feedback the T's for taming the ages for
hacking the e is for engaging in the r
is for reinventing and at the center
is of course the mindset of the
organization the culture that is there
thus far we've actually been focusing on
finding people and so that's where we
are but before we move to the other
elements John can you give us a sense
when you advise startups and you work
with them you know what's the ratio of
the number of people you meet and the
higher as you close is it like one
higher for every ten people you meet
there is it much more than that
and it's not even a useful diagnostic
yeah that's an interesting I don't know
quite a characterize there but I would
say is that we think a lot of a lot
about pipelines so I focused less on the
output which is the number of hires and
more on like how do you build process
flow see you see enough people and then
of diversity into the pipeline so well
we spend a lot of time a lot of time in
early starts is like how do we find and
Howie Howie how do you find and evaluate
the right people then how do we
Commission to come and so they think by
the pipeline is like we have to go look
through LinkedIn all the resumes and you
have to filter that down to calling out
like sitting emails and like see who
responds to you and then doing phone
screens and then you go phone screen
attendant excreting a technical screen
to an on-site interview on-site
interview to eventually even offer an
offer to acceptance and we think about
like this is a pipe on Sycamore nine
pipeline and she's you've got numbers
and then you've got conversion ratios in
each one mm-hm and so the questions both
like how to avoid I think how to get
true positives I kind of like false
positives out of a false negative and
then we just really focus a lot of the
conversions like the most expensive two
parts of the of that of that funnel hmm
our on-site interviews because you bring
somebody in they spent half a day or a
day with basically your core team your
most important team and then which is a
very expensive operation and then once
you find something you like them and
make them an offer you really want to
close so the - but conversion numbers I
really focus on are the number of people
who've been on site how many of those do
you make off with you know and I try to
I try to make sure that I think I think
most artists would probably like 1/4 to
1/3
moving outside I think that you can
build a more robust a better filter than
that so we try to get closer to half and
then you offer to acceptance that's
critical and that's a it's been a lot of
time being very active in how do you
make the offer and you make the offer
when they're ready to get it you do a
lot of things around it to make sure
that they're ready to get the offer to
accept the offer that you really want to
be well over 50 percent mm-hmm it's
harder now because we'll need a lot of
Millennials in particular gathering up a
lot of offers now five or six to choose
from hmm so I have a question sort of
you're focusing on how important it is
to have a high yield rate so I would
sort of do a yes and with another
perspective I'm thinking of especially
in the old days at Netflix we spend a
lot of time talking to crazy Patti
McCord about their system and and Patti
described how a lot of what their goal
was was before people got into interview
that they would give them such a
sufficient cultural preview that people
would self screen out so that the people
who would agree to be interviewed
actually would want the job do you do
any thing to sort of discourage but
people who won't fit to make themself
out of the pool yeah I think this is
like critical Thunder saying what the
organization you're building is so Patti
famously built this Netflix culture deck
which yeah it was a little self
aggrandizing is a little bit like it's
not exactly right but I think they were
they're trying to they're trying to
distill their values in such a
provocative way you like would either
say oh my god I love that more yeah be
repulsed by no vacation policy uh and I
think either you're a superstar you're
fired
yeah I think yeah I would hire me in
here trying to you're trying to elicit
is like a strong match so you're trying
to figure out like how do you build a
superstar that's really a company trying
to figure out how do you build build or
relation with the spiciest people not
I'm not the best on average and like the
spiky is in certain areas so I think the
culture deck was a really good thing
that she did you know more recently
Henry Ward he shares the same kind of
thing like here's how we do it here's
how we interview if you don't like it
and you know I remember yeah I think the
best leaders do this so I remember when
Steve I was at Apple but Steve Jobs came
back I think it's what you guys this
before but he gave this big
each one time and Apple was I think
we're training for like basically a two
billion dollars in cash and the market
cap of Apple is two billion dollars
we're trading about at cash anybody
thought everything about my son and
Steve came back said look we're gonna
reinvent the company and we're gonna all
your all your shares are underwater and
so we're gonna Rivest your shares it's
all gonna be in the money but they're
gonna professed for three years and
we're gonna go I'm gonna build amazing
products and change the world if you
don't believe it get the hell out and
that what that did no he left they all
galvanized the people who wanted to be
on them well isn't it the same meeting
where Michael Dell predicted that the
company's got a business and Steve's
response I'm not sure why I say so the
likely after it's the yeah Michael Dell
and the Dell are nice call me y'all
remember doc computer important days
actually there's a dollar term but the
yeah something I'm Adele earnings call
said what should I believe it some money
and then Michael Dell famous he said
well they should give it back this show
then the company giving back to
shareholders and right after Steve said
that we're gonna read us your options
some someone who had more courage than I
do got up and said hey would extinct and
the QA said hey what do you think Robert
Michael Dallas said about half what we
should do and it was this dead silence
and and Steve like he just was quiet
he's David he said after he said that
like everybody in the place we're
following so that do that that's a great
I'm sorry and I write about with with
excellence of scale you need two things
this is straight from his work on social
movements you need a hot cause you need
to crank up this collective anger and
pride and you need to link it to a
tangible behaviors me that's the perfect
example well he was changing the options
but then I got emotions going to I want
to pick up on one thing that you just
mentioned a while ago John you you use
the term match between a recruit and the
company in the hiring process
I'm assuming by that you meant fit you
know in other words there's the new
recruit fit into the company does the
company fit with the aspirations
do we always hire individuals for fit
what about scrunch don't you hire people
to stretch the ability of the company to
get it to Domo do you do those kinds of
hires differently or is it the same
thing yeah I think this is a critical
point so I think when you say the word
fit knocking it's shorthand for a
culture thing well they fit our culture
right which is I think you guys know the
studies for the idea which is very often
short and for this person is like me
right yeah my favorite person meet tend
to reinforce Majin a diversity it's I
think when I say match whether I think
you're trying to do is understand what
are the criteria are hiring for and does
this person match those criteria and
you're trying to you're trying to pull
out the I think you're trying to as much
as you can make make the criteria
explicit so you can he can be somewhat
objectives I think that we're human this
were all my features but I do you think
that I try not to use words like fit or
come your bed it's impossible I think it
it elides a whole bunch of a bunch of
hidden personal I mean you've seen I'm
sure a lot of people and interviewed
them and I want to focus on the
interview part I realize of course
interviews have their own limitations
and you have to actually qualify the
prospect as you mentioned in a variety
of other ways but I'm curious in your
interview process have you found a
useful diagnostic question or have you
found something that immediately
surfaces red flags for you
yeah I think I probably interviewed you
ever take 10,000 people in mine I find
the more people I interview the less the
less I believe in my ability to
interview hmm and what I mean is you're
not fitting the literature good for you
I think there was a time when I was very
confident in my ability to spend 15
minutes with somebody and
No Wow and I think the more people I've
interviewed the more I feel like
interviews are these like profoundly
overloaded contacts yeah you don't have
a shared background you don't have
shared understanding goals
it's a very the power dynamic is all
messed up right and so I've come to
think of interviews as a very limited
the specific type of information and so
I think there's about there's things you
can munch I think you that you can learn
whether if people are somewhat defensive
you can learn how people react to
questions and how they react to stress
situation so you tend to say so I think
that if you find people blaming you
don't feel talking about their last job
and say oh those guys did this wrong
here's all the time a lot of blaming
that's a that's a clear red flag I think
the green the pastas are are a little
harder so I I tend to I think we're all
different I think some people come in
with a roster of questions when I ask I
come in and say hey what are you curious
about we understood how are you
processing this so far as I'm trying to
I try to code instruct knowledge at then
during but especially at times block is
done it's talking about the priority
Parker's referencing now you know our to
read from then he'll famously say if I
could do an hour of referencing or an
hour interviewing only no reference not
oh yeah and the point is that you know
in an interview you can only get to the
can only observe the experience you have
during the time whereas referencing you
can talk about months or years of
collaboration now it's still different
like human beings don't like saying
negative things about other most what's
you in being said but until you've got
to figure out how to elicit truth those
references and that that's that's harder
to do because you you have to build a
strength of network engineer reputation
and and build the context where we will
take that yes yeah that well I won't
name the organization's there's certain
organizations where if you get the worst
if it's a current employee you'll have a
really positive references you get rid
of them really gotta be care that says
they want to export their problem is a
they won't give sport their problems
yeah I think most people think the
interview is useful because it's
possibly get good at interviewing
yourself hmm
whereas you can only get good at
referencing when building a network and
a history
one time when very few people will lie
to read in front of lead in about a
reference because they know he knows
everyone right right it's but that
that's that's a product of 20 or 30
years of building so in other words what
referencing is is it actually provides
you know validation from multiple
sources that's kind of what I want to
green on the outing the time as well so
we have this little wheel with the
farther framework we've been focusing on
finding people let's assume there is a
start up here it's gone to 25 people
sure from like five people which of
these elements what do you think is the
important thing for this startup at 25
to focus on yes I think in a lot of ways
this the way the wheel works is um is in
order so you have to find people you
have to get them to do things and when
little good for small and they you don't
have to do a lot of aligning so you say
hey let's go build this product let's go
so this consulting service whatever it
is and you've got enough shared
background that you can kind of just go
off and do it you're kind of be in your
own lanes and you're going and the
reason that's powerful is because
everything is happening as fast as it
can possibly happen so it's all
happening in your brain and the reason
you start to get processes over times
like you start to get teams and who
can't see inside the founders brain
mm-hmm
and so the founder brain like process is
the motion of pulling stuff out of the
founders and saying oh here's a cadence
here a weekly meeting here's the way we
build things and you're basically trying
to pull all the constructs out of your
out of your brain so that other people
can can contribute come on and so I
would say 25 by the time gets to 25
you've got smaller groups right and
you've had to have some process and
you're starting to figure out like oh
the groups need to figure out how to
work together when my experience has
been the groups of three to six people
give or take or about the right size
that's not evidence to support that yeah
I think once you get to seven or eight
or nine there become places to hide so
it's this this sort of transition from
three to six to about a 30 person firm
is something that we we've all been
involved a little bit but what what some
of the early processes
think that are useful and what are the
red flags that they're adding process
that makes that dance destructive
friction so what do you suggest adding
and what do you suggest waiting yeah I
try to layer in lightweight ways of
committing of the each group committing
to each other
okay like the it starts with like weekly
commitments or weekly sprints or maybe I
get twenty five people's a little early
for basically talking about quarterly
but you're trying to bring each group
you're trying to say here's the here's
the work that we expect to get done in
this so aligning the rhythms of the of
the small number of teams yeah I got
rhythms because you're trying to define
like what to expect and and you're
trying to be in Mozilla we were bigger
but we had different groups and so my
favorite figure we had these quarterly
goals and we had some groups like IT
information technology who would in a
quarter they would do like basically
exactly 190th of the work every day of
the ninety days and then you had groups
like the innovation group who would do
approximately zero for some of the work
for like the first 88 the 88 days and
then they would like pull like
all-nighters for a week and get them all
done at the end and what you're trying
to teach is like that's okay yeah you're
trying to teach about heterogeneous
things as long as you you as long as you
agree or commitments not anti do you
think you're trying to layer these on
lightly to start with and you get
heavier weight processes over time but
like you know my first start is like a
team League just sent out mail on Friday
say hey here are the poor things that
our team's doing next week here the four
things that we said we were gonna do and
here's whether we did them or not okay
you're in here the four things need help
hmm and that's a super simple like
lightweight email and with 25 people you
can like call it in five groups you like
they'll see all of it right so let's
assume that this startup has grown from
25 to a hundred yeah so which of these
things becomes kind of important then do
you spend time on aligning or real-time
feedback yeah oh you team right so I
think nothing here is always important
and I think that in contrast to how
people think that performance management
down which is like every annual
I find basically counterproductive
saying you've always forgotten my
December you've forgotten what happened
in February and it's everybody thinks
they're above average but they aren't
the way the lake will like what we got a
problem and so I think that by the time
it's about a hundred you start so he's
continued from San Antonio Texas well I
was there last week and high school
there but by the time you get to a
hundred people it's likely that these
lightweight processes have turned heavy
and so I think the in a lot of ways the
founder was the founder has the moral
authority to do is run around and like
short-circuit them
and so you say oh well I t's not gonna
talk to marketing until marketing gets
their goals and asks i order and uhm
you just run people together and jam it
together so I find that founders start
to hack things and you start to ask
questions like does this process really
represent what we're trying to do so I
think that hacking and reinvention is
that is the most important thing social
so well there's there's two things
implied in that the first one is is that
the CEO and actually the senior teams
job needs to evolve because they got to
start delegating stuff and I'm just sad
you went to this admissable you get to
Missoula there's 12 people and you left
there's 500 so number like that so you
have you had to go through this
personally to figure out like you
couldn't be everywhere at once towards
them yeah how did you figure out when to
when to which stuff to keep doing in
which stuff to let go yeah so I think
Jeff Weiner who is running thin talks
the most about aligning and how you have
cultures and in what what you what you
what I mean when I say aligning is
you're trying to make sure that if
meetings happened without you then
roughly the same thing happens whether
you're in the and so I think what that
means you just have to spend time
together and so I think almost every
team that I know had the senior staff
meeting once a week when they just spent
time it's like relatively unstructured
yeah I think Apple spends all day
Mondays together
look at everything across the business
you know I ended up doing skip level
meetings where every couple weeks we
have me and meeting with all the
directors and VPS and and I'll be trying
to model behavior and model models in
this and model all that stuff um I
remember talking to you once in and you
were worried that people didn't feel
safe having constructive argument so you
said that you were actually holding
constructive arguments and in the always
so people could see that it was okay
yeah that was kind of amazing yeah what
you're trying to do is I think that the
best managers are specific and explicit
and candid and non-judgmental by and
large so I think you're trying to say
that like the only thing I really
penalized in Mozilla was if people were
hiding the ball so somebody said so you
say well what do you need help with
Camille said we got it
like that would always be like a sign
where it's are asking lots of things
like make sure you have it like the more
the way they are the more you can I just
include we have some interesting
questions from our viewers
oh good I thought we've kind of seen so
one of the colleagues here gamma I think
says I run a business that employs 13
people
we have built a particular culture but
it's resulted in a culture that I don't
when is the right time to work on the
company culture is it in the aligning of
the organization how does one change
culture which of the elements of the
wheel would you intervene yeah yeah
that's interesting I think that yeah my
Mitch caper we charted Lotus he had his
phrase he said he need to build a house
want to live in and what he meant by
that is this this which is like you need
to build a company you want to work out
that's right and so if you build a
company that you're supposed to because
you think the Stanford GSB things that
he says go tell me this way or you're
trying to maximize shareholder value be
very travesty and Hoover again if you
feel the company you think you're
supposed to build almost always you end
up with this thing that doesn't quite
look like you like you back and so I
think it's it's important all along to
say well here's here's what I'm trying
to do here's where I think the deltas
and when I say culture I think on tulip
think it means like you know what snacks
we have and where do you go for dinner
and like how long our lunches and stuff
what got a t-shirt su wear when I say
culture I mean it's how you make
decisions what you celebrate will do it
to you what you what you reward and what
you penalize and I this has to be
constant so I think you have to build
channels to the whole company so that
every week every day you can say oh look
at look at Sheree who did this thing
this is amazing helps the company know
you're being defensive about this I'm
gonna ask you a whole bunch of questions
I'm gonna make you feel like like you
don't want to be defensive again yes but
the way we describe it ha ni is that we
asked what sacred and taboo and we and
we look to see if if they actually have
something that fits their business and
then we also look for agreement not to
use the name of a company but I use the
name of a company right after our book
came out in 2014 we were sitting around
a table with eight top people in
engineering and Twitter and so huggy
night we just asked the question was s
what's sacred and what's taboo they
couldn't answer the question each person
said well I can tell you about my last
company Salesforce Apple whatever but
they actually didn't know what was
saving in taboo at Twitter movie that's
not a good sign yeah I think the other
point which is I think most companies
slide through these things and they
don't make it so number one they feel
like cultures fixed right and so they
don't explicitly change it the other is
I think change its little bits at a time
and what I found is you grew from
Mozilla was I couldn't change my message
every day I needed it to be the same
message until there was a change and
then I didn't say everybody were
changing now I'm a big break and we just
put through this with one of the
companies I work with where they started
with four core values and one of them
was kindness for example and look I
value kindness we try to teach it to our
kids every single day and I try to
remember it in my own life but the it
wasn't working for us as a corporate
value and so the CEO actually just went
we wrote it and so you say okay we're
gonna we're gonna go and redo this and
we're gonna acknowledge that it's a
change yeah and like sign
riri-san me up or move on and that's
okay that's one my favorite example so
that is somewhere near the end of his
tenure Andy Grove of Intel Fame he took
having fun off the badges because he
said that's disingenuous we do all sorts
of things that aren't fun and we're
gonna ask you to do things that aren't
fun to succeed it I think we should be
honest about it that those are my kind
of favorite examples of a CEO telling
the truth and you know having a good
reason for it
so I want to go back to some of the
systems and so there's an interesting
how do you stress test some of these
elements of the way
so can we stress test alignment or
finding people and how do you know your
alignment is working and you know you're
finding the right kind of people I mean
is there a stress test that you'd
recommend I think that's the question
readers are contemplating doing this I
think that you always have to bring it
back to what's the organism why does he
already exist and what are you trying to
do and like the truth is like all you
really have is proxy metrics because
it's hard to say well we aren't revenue
to behind this quarter and every
employee to figure out how to do that so
you've got or ever you might associate
with user metrics or hiring metrics or
whatever and so I think you've got to
figure out like what are we measuring
ourselves against and how do we tell
whether we're getting better or worse
and a lot of times I think you're you
make your practicing making commitments
to each other like making making
commitments and and being honest all you
get the commitments or not so let me
turn the question another way around
maybe to rethink of stress tests as a
question of variance so you know in any
organization you have average quality or
the mean and you have the variance of
yeah now you know when would you
recommend that you know is high variance
good or is it bad or put another way
well it's great to find people how do
you go about firing people I mean do you
need to do that quickly in a starter or
yes so just this is something I mean I
talk about a lot and I always think of
the Netflix versus they had cat no model
so
patty McCord then that puts no
performance improvement plan they walk
in your gun and I had a guy Eric Olsen
now at stitch fix he basically described
firing 80 out of about 80 out of 120
people and he said I love them they just
didn't fit anymore and yeah
and then there's that CAD no and yet
when we interviewed Ed we said n so what
do you do with non-performance said well
I used to fire him quicker but now what
I do when I did that it would create
fear but now what I do is I wait for
everybody to tell me that that person
sucks and then when I fire them there's
no fear so he said I've learned to wait
longer and that was but that was one of
the only may be the only person hug
unites completely stop he might have me
he didn't say they might even talk about
firing directors and patroller yeah
but still there's me there's two
completely different philosophies yeah I
think well so I think Ed's a very smart
guy so I think the one that says
something like this and has a difference
these things different yeah that's right
I think also that the missional wisdom
would be our fast fire fact yes I think
either is fine as long as you understand
what your philosophy is and you are
explicit about an intentional about it
so what I mean is that mmm I kind of you
make hiring a person if I'm coming to
work for your company is you're making a
two-sided commitment so the person's
committed to work for your company then
nobody is committing to do some set of
things to have that person be successful
this is how I think now just what that
means is that you're there's a burden on
you enough to make the hard decision and
once you do that there's some obligation
you have to do to do what you said
that's back to the mindset yeah there's
agreements and helps you know I think
there's other ways to do that but that's
my philosophy and that that will tend to
mean that you tend to you're trying to
understand what the context is and what
the person is feeling and you try to say
well here's the gap
can we talk together on how to close the
gap in some time box Leigh that's how I
do it which is kind of in the middle
between far fast and like let her bite
tell me there's a bar yeah I wanna find
that a little passive by the way so I
find it sound like he's doing it because
empirically he's realized that it's it's
um net positive or more positive to do
it this way too
so that if I tell them it's bad right I
find that a little bit passive
management's almost never in my
experience very good that's interesting
let me push all of us on this a little
bit I'm kind of wondering is it a matter
of personal philosophy or listening to
me you have a lot to do with what the
business is all about so when I think of
it then Pixar it's a creative business
and very long term kind of right long
term time horizon yeah where risk-taking
is important I'm wondering maybe the
reason he delays firing is he doesn't
want fear to chill risk-taking on the
other hand when I look at some of the
companies you advise there the task is a
little different
often it's a new product development
chance and in any years you would know
better than I would in any new product
development task it's the weakest link
or dictates the pace of new product and
so does it actually have to do with how
the task differs between new product
development and creativity yeah I think
you know that that is for sure true
because even even inside us one company
have different firing patterns across
their phone yeah that's right so sales
is very numerically my engineers gonna
work doesn't science about that why do
salespeople why our sales you'll pay a
commission why they make so much money
and like the truth is like because if
they miss their number their fire and so
sales Tesla sales companies look like
this all the time goes into your content
like this okay but interesting the
different type of functions and be
different outcomes but anything is
important to be intentional and say this
is a commitment we're making right for
you so what whimpers engagement become
an issue when you become 50,000 or when
you become 5,000 or 500 or you know can
you give us a you know when this
reinvention become a top priority yeah
question it was more like when when does
disengagement happen and when is this
engagement start so it starts to hurt
the company I think that uh I don't know
the most interesting companies
everyone's pre-engaged
I do you think that you mentioned
Hewlett Packard which is kinda ancient
history now but the Packard used to talk
about management of are walking around
right and bwa he would he would just
walk around and he'd sit and engineers
that's a to know what you're doing and
my sense is that that's that was a
very very effective way of managing and
it's connecting and it connected it
strips away at the organization chart
like myself you know you guys know that
my my son our CEO Mozilla my
understanding des is basically in the
middle hallway right and I put it there
because I wanted to make sure that as
people were walking back and forth we
always made eye contact make eye contact
that means you almost always have to
talk to us there was one way of just
encouraging people to talk and say hello
to even somebody who might be in a
different world or three levels or
whatever right right so again I'm
keeping track of time here so the some
months ago I invited this executive from
uber you know Bob and I wrote a case
study of course an uber and one for them
but this was a different executive and
he had worked in uber fur so I asked him
I said hey how long have you worked in
uber and he said I worked there for four
years and I said four years and he
laughed and he said I know it's four
years but for me it feels like I work in
16 different companies each quarter it
was a different company was he sort of
exaggerating or was he where is this how
fast companies change as they scale yeah
I think Luber is a very special case
because these are the just massive
ambition and massive growth trajectory
mm-hm but even it was our involvement I
talk about organizations as prototypes
ooh
we just pulled out organization last
week where we changed some things and
said look this is an eight we prototype
uh-huh and I feel like it's it's framing
it up for people's like oh well this
these are not my reports this is not my
aura classes this is a this is a an
experiment that we're gonna have to see
how work gets done and we're trying to
create some distance oh she Asian the
organizational structure itself yeah how
do you find that people get really
locked in the word structures you know
like here my reports here's my or I
one-on-one and I try to break that
everywhere I can I feel like you know
facts on the ground facts inside the
company don't change they change rapidly
and so there's some things you want to
get locked in you want to get the sales
execution engine going like at the QA
and you're going I think for a lot of
things where you're the terrain is
unknown you're not sure you have the
right or effect size so that's two
into that a little bit uh one of the
things that we look for is if basically
you have it
so you see you start using SOPs to do
the exact same thing and that's great
when you're doing the right thing yeah
but when you're doing the what is it the
wrong thing the right way and you can go
down really quick yep
any red flags you look for that people
are just doing what they've always done
because they've always done it and you
gotta you gotta put the brakes yeah so
the the red flag is when you get people
not asking questions so silence is not
cold yeah
so what I the very early days of data
science in 2005 and we brought it so
many before it's called data science
into Mozilla because we had 100 million
users on we just couldn't tell what's
happening in it so rotted a scientist
who work for Steve Levitt on
Freakonomics in and so he just started
generating reports and I had him sent it
to me every night at 7 o'clock and my
executive team didn't like this very
much because it was just got home having
dinner and they would see this room and
they see this report coming through and
then I could 703 like there be me
responding it's like why does this look
like this and Mike down in Germany and
what it's like this and I'm trying to
teach people like everytime everyday
look at things and say oh why does it
look like this happening question yeah
it's people didn't love it because they
felt like they had to answer the
questions but then they started asking
questions I don't know it's about three
or several two before IKEA I want to
sort of step in here and invite our
viewers to send more questions yes we've
got about 10 15 minutes more I'm going
to sort of pick a couple of questions
but please add them these questions are
gifts for us so don't forget that
so one lovely question that somebody put
up but I think it was a little bit
before with titles see you ought to
think about all the shops to people I'm
curious what the research doesn't is
like the I thought I struggle with this
sometimes I think about titles is free
gives like they are early in the
organization it's bigger they become
quite expensive they apply things about
how what the organization looks like you
know a lot of a lot of companies today
will throw in our heart directors or VP
they'll call everybody ahead of some
thread to indicate leadership and
ownership I I think this is a
challenging question I don't I don't
really have a good answer to I think
that you should be clear about who's on
your executive team I think you should
be clear about ownership and I think to
the extent UK you should be clear about
compensation progression Ron
so having five or six levels you will
progress through a cop levels almost
always should be division titles yes
yeah yeah yeah
I relate a little guess this is one
right sentiment where the decision
rights are unclear what that leads to is
a bunch of dysfunctional conflict where
people act like cats scratching get to
the top so I think that's the most
important thing I think they're artists
they're directly responsible ten jewels
and say this is the person responsible
for this set of decisions
I guess the clearest crews just better
do it it sometimes means if things fall
in the cracks and give you a weird study
on titles yeah we actually did a
mischievous study and titles where what
we did was in this experiment with
eighty-two new venture teams in the
treatment condition we asked all the
teams in both conditions were
four-person teams they had to build a
prototype we had to get an external
panel of judges to evaluate the
prototype but in the treatment
Commission all that we asked was we
asked people and said come up with a job
title that showcases your unique
personal swath so and it was
extraordinary people came up with titles
like guru of cybersecurity defender of
the source code chief shoes er chief
banana chief instigator and we were kind
of quite surprised at the end of the
experiment teams where people chose
their own job titles they actually built
a prototype faster but most importantly
the prototypes they built they at least
in the eyes of an external panel of
judges were measurably superior to the
prototypes prepared by the other teams
in the control condition so my sort of
speculation is the moment and we
actually had evidence of this when you
ask people to choose their own job
titles the first thing is you're
actually triggering a sense of ownership
you chose the title the other equally
vital thing was in the teams where
people chose their own job titles it was
very clear who should do what there was
no confusion about the division of labor
so you know people were specialists in
I went to them they were supposed to do
that you know there wasn't like hey this
is my issue this is not my show I'm not
you know etc so knowledge utilization
actually unfolded far more efficiently
in such teams and in teams where
everybody had like cookie cutter Titans
it was kind of okay you just didn't know
who was good at what those who say
that's not my job and on my area that's
the biggest fire across everything I
think that's the number one things I go
that's not my job right any other
question that strikes your fancy Bob
John somebody asked about how you build
culture and remote workforces is an
important question I think we're seeing
in so compass as well people move we're
starting develop centers everywhere else
yeah Mozilla was a big distributed work
for us because people everywhere
probably 30 other countries on the world
even though we're talking they're people
and yeah I think it's just like anything
else you have to decide like how are you
gonna communicate when you have to test
test the fidelity of communications
that's engagement I think you also just
have to figure out ways to get people to
be in person together often to like the
rule I mean in Mozilla was we had enough
money where I said anytime need to get
together to work on telling somebody
flock somewhere hmm and I don't care
where it is just figure out where to be
and where to work for a week and just be
there and I'll scream if it gets too
expensive and I never so very minor
thing for those of you interested in the
question of virtual teams that are
geographically dispersed our wonderful
colleague Pam Hinds of the School of
Engineering has actually done very
interesting research in that area and if
I recall her findings this goes back to
your point again John what she found was
the two things that if you didn't watch
these things geographically dispersed
teams could become subcultures you're in
Shanghai I'm in San Francisco and then
you kind of fight about everything the
two things that they in her work with
mark Mortensen that they found were very
valuable to deal with dispersion was
amazingly the frequency of communication
the most really face to face and is to
face early in the relationship and it's
actually frequent spontaneous
communication as opposed to prescribed
communication and the other thing was
what they found was that this
spontaneous communication actually
showed up a sense of shared identity I
would say I think it has to be
multimodal so you know mostly use IRC
which is sort of it's in the proto slack
I have mixed feelings my stocking stack
is very productive in many ways and
encounter pros in other ways but we used
sort of a slack stock vacation thing by
also tweeted to a lot of employees that
it was going on but also in the kitchens
like we had open Skype or junior hangout
conversations that were between Mountain
View and Squanto just open all the time
so if you're going to get coffee in the
afternoon in Toronto you can see
something getting coffee in the kitchen
and oh that's we need for spontaneous
interactions people who are random so
and I think the other thing maybe is
like monkeying with like desk and desk
and furniture layouts pre-op yeah you
say you stars move things around so just
just on on slack so hugging our project
no an organizational friction and I at
least our take at this point might taken
one speak for you is that slack can be
good or maybe not so good but it's as a
platform it's okay where the problem
occurs is when you start getting
platform overload and literally you can
sit and watch my daughter has a job like
this she's using about eight different
platforms at once she's using slack
she's she's using email she's using
Salesforce and that's just some of them
I can go on and on and and when you're
still just having this overload being
able to sort of keep track where
everything is it really makes it hard
for people to do their work no matter
how skilled they are so so to me that's
the bigger problem with sort of the
tragedy of the Commons and maybe each
one might be a little bit better but
then it destroys sort of the whole you
see how many screens that you'll see
where she works how many screens people
have open on their little laptop is just
amazing I suspect this is a
transitionary problem I suspect like my
you know my 13 year old son will be
playing for tonight and watching for
nine and doing a face time doing all
these things at the same time in text
so my sense is that this is it just
feels awkward to us because we're kind
of old drains like one thing on the
screen at a time but I do think all
these backwards are good at different
things like I think that the
expectations of norms like if somebody
texted me like like I expect I'm gonna
text in my back provide alors it's make
he so he calls you know whatever and I
think slack has different expectations
which is like whoever's around answer
your question could right away right
there's different norms that get built
up for a variety of reasons I think
these are all different media well but
wouldn't you have to many it gets then
you're trying to do your job I think it
I think much as we like to spend more
time we're nearing rehear any have any
parting thoughts for our viewers John I
think my only sense would be that what
we do in the GSB class we teach as we
say two things more anything else like
be active in all these processes and be
intentional about them hmm and so
understand what you're trying to build
and don't ever sort of lean back and
wait for it wait for things that happen
to be more accurate the the one thing I
would add which comes up in our work all
sorts of ways is have somebody in your
life who you trust and cares about you
who can tell you and think when you're
screwing up mm-hmm there's lots of
people can tell you you're screwing up
you might not trust but those are the
most valuable people and and if you look
at research on self-awareness so the
worst person to ask whether they're
competent whether they're jerk is that
person themselves and the best person
asks are people who know them and care
about them yeah my foot if I can just
add there you know my big contribution
I'd like to swiftly underline what John
mentioned which is don't sleepwalk your
way to a culture make sure you actually
actively design it and it's the outcome
of you know choice so to speak and I
think the other interesting so the
bookend is what Bob sort of mentioned is
also very vital in there is as a start
up schemes and to
John's point there's a lot of
reinvention when there's a lot of
reinvention if you're a CEO or if you're
the founder you're often leading from a
position of not knowing and when you
lead from a position of not knowing for
some of us it engenders anxiety and if
you only get in touch with your feelings
of anxiety you're bound to classify more
things in the environment as threats
then as opportunities but if on the
other hand you pursue Bob's advice and
get feedback from trusted people you're
able to move from the door called doubt
and uncertainty hopefully to a room
called confidence and that in turn might
allow that person that's a very huggy
Rao can't comment because whenever I
started having an anxiety attack he
looks and he says let's just think of it
as an adventure even though things are
all screwed up in the matter it's
amazing you can just see it now no
matter how things screwed up are he just
keeps he thinks it's fun and I sort of
learned to kind of go along you know the
thing it's actually a great model and
you're good about learning from mistakes
and stuff but you just oh this is really
cool all that thing work we all do make
a mistake so keep those two things in
mind as you're building a culture and in
fact in many ways John's comments and
Bob's comments are wonderful bookends
you deliberately need to design culture
on the one hand but on the other to
Bob's point you really need to underline
how you manage how you lead when you
don't know and to Bob's point again when
you don't know you can't afford to be a
hippopotamus
you better be an elephant when you look
at hippopotamus the hippopotamus is the
biggest part of the hippos face of
course is the mouth and when you lead
when you know we use the mouth often but
hopefully when you don't know you become
an elephant you use your ears so good
luck on your elephantine adventures
thank you all so very much for your
thank you and thank you John thank you
thank you to today's speakers in to all
of you for attending if you enjoyed our
webinar today you might also be
interested in some of these courses I
hope to see you all next
thank you
you